omicron has now hit the united states
there's been one case detected in
california which means i guess we have
to have a travel ban from california
sorry guys
in a white house news briefing dr
anthony fauci the greatest of all
doctors except for the the much belly
hood joe biden he announced that uh it
was one person who traveled from south
africa on november 22 and tested
positive for coven 19 on november 29th
that person is self-quarantining close
contacts have tested negative
the person was fully vast and is
experiencing mild symptoms which are
improving at this point again i remind
you there is no evidence that omicron is
more deadly than delta in fact there's
some evidence that omicron is less
deadly than delta
but according to anthony fauci even if
you believe that omicron is less deadly
than than delta you shouldn't be
sanguine
so he was asked a simple question was
was dr anthony fauci okay and the
question was asked by a reporter let's
say that omicron is more transmissible
but less deadly than delta
wouldn't it be good for people to get
omicron as opposed to delta
wouldn't that be better because then
like you assume that everybody's gonna
get delta as i've said before there is
no world in which people just live
completely virus free for the rest of
time it's like the flu is like a common
cold you're gonna get it you're gonna
get immunity through natural processes
or you're gonna get immunity through the
vacs so if you now have to choose
between getting one of these two
variants delta
or or oh
macron if it turns out and omicron is
less deadly than delta wouldn't you
rather have omicron so the reporter
asked voucher that he's like no never no
one must ever get this disease no one so
they just keep baiting and switching
they're like yes it's endemic yes we're
gonna have to learn to live with the
virus but no one should ever get it good
luck with that dude
would there be any public health benefit
to furthering it spread by lifting
travel restrictions for example so out
compete the delta variant you're talking
about something really dangerous you're
talking about let a lot of people get
infected to see if in fact you could
protect them that's something that i
think almost all infectious disease
people with any knowledge about
infectious disease would not say that's
a good idea
um so i'm just wondering why he says
that
is he is he challenging the idea of
natural immunity is that what he's doing
right there because natural immunity is
a well-established epidemio
epidemiological fact in fact the data on
on delta suggests that a natural
immunity to delta is probably more
durable than vaccine immunity despite
the cdc's proudest stations to the
contrary they're israeli studies
demonstrating that that's probably not
true uh the the cdc's protestations that
is
so anthony fauci says are you suggesting
that we let people get sick to get
natural immunity no i'm suggesting you
have no ability to stop the spread of
disease that everything you have
attempted to do has been a giant failure
including the mass mandates in the
lockdowns
and so you're going to have to choose
how you wish to live with this
but falchi is just a bag of mixed
messages why the white house continues
to trot out this person who has lost all
public trust is beyond me
at what point does the booster
become part of the mandate yeah i can't
answer that right now but i know that
for the time being the official
definition of fully vaccinated is two
but do you see that changing we keep
having these variants we're concerned
about that it could change it could
change it could change yes
well i don't know let's see what what
rolls out now i mean i know if i say
it's going to change it's going to get
spread out that that's it we don't know
right now whether it should change but
it might
it might change it might not but it
might change but it also might not but
it might change again they have no
approach here they're just pretending
they have an approach
and by the way again
there's no evidence that the vaccines
are not standing up to this thing at
least in terms of hospitalization and
death which is the only thing i care
about i'm not gonna i'm gonna keep
repeating this until people get it
through their thick skulls it does not
matter if you get omicron if you don't
get that sick i don't understand why
this is remotely controversial
all three of my kids had colds this week
they're all fine because this is called
living as a human being on planet earth
people get sick as long as they are not
threatened with serious conditions or
death who gives a crap
even the biden administration used to
used to say this now apparently they
just can't make up their minds and again
the fact that they can't make up their
minds underscores what i have been
saying now for months
for more than a year at this point
people who refuse to acknowledge that
government cannot solve all of their
problems are the same people who believe
that we have to keep locking down we
have to keep being scared because after
all if they ever admit that government
can't solve all of our problems we might
actually start taking our lives into our
own hands and that wouldn't that be a
disaster wouldn't that be a disaster
here's a top research scientist on ms on
cnbc saying yeah by the way uh it looks
kind of like the vaccines are durable
against domicron and you're all
panicking because you're stupid
t cells are what's really protecting us
from severe disease from covert
pneumonia and our t cells are very uh
insensitive not affected by variants
to any significant degree
so
there's lots of reasons for optimism
that this is not you know some
horrible situation that we're in the
vaccine should hold up against severe
disease especially with people who are
boosted
okay so what are we panicking over
exactly what exactly are we panicking
over okay so the answer is again it goes
to the root baseline belief of democrats
of many people on the left that they are
capable of fixing your life if you give
them control this is true in economics
it's true in social life it is true when
it comes to disease ron claine put out
the most insane tweet of the day
yesterday so this is the actual chief of
staff of the white house ron klain is
the shadow president because joe biden
is no longer with us he sadly departed
this earth at least on a mental level i
mean if we're talking about viability
i'm not sure that joe biden is viable at
this point as a human joe biden left us
many many months ago
ronald klein is the guy who's actually
making policy at the white house so
there's a columnist named greg ipp who
writes for the wall street journal and
he says kovid carved a partisan divide
through the united states democrats have
been much more cautious and protective
which manifests itself as generally
lower infections and deaths but also
much weaker economic outcomes omicron
could perpetuate that
okay so here's the thing it sort of
depends on the state as far as as death
per million ratio because new york did
worse than florida and new york is about
the same size as florida florida is much
more open but focusing on the economic
statement right there right where he's
correct about this that they are killing
their own economies ron claims we tell
quote nope
stronger coveted measures produce
stronger economic outcomes that's why
jobs growth and economic activity are up
this year significantly over last year
it's so insane that he says this it's
almost difficult to know where exactly
to begin
it's like really
strong and coveted measures produce
stronger economic outcomes which is why
we're up this year no we're up this year
because people got vaccinated and they
went back to work that's why we're up
this year your own president says this
but he's saying that it's stronger
coveted measures like lockdowns
presumably and mass mandates that
generate stronger economic if that's the
case why wasn't strong economic growth
the thing last year
after all we actually locked in our
houses for months at a time last year
we masked mandate i was living in
california last year and let me tell you
that place was like that place was
locked down tighter in tech
and economic growth was completely
stagnant it destroyed the economy of the
state
so ronald clinton is just crazy stronger
coveted measures produce stronger
economic outcomes again just get rid of
covid there
and um and and the word stronger
economic and
bottom line is
that sentence without any of those
signifiers would read stronger measures
produce stronger outcomes that is the
democratic party platform in a nutshell
stronger measures produce stronger
outcomes
more regulation more top-down control
produces stronger outcomes now it's a
lie it's been a lie it was lie in the
soviet union with regards to the economy
and it's a lie with regards to kovid and
the economy
and by the way when i say it's a lie i
don't mean that he's just getting it
wrong i mean he is a liar because this
is perfectly available data patrick
graffini
who is a republican pollster he put out
a chart showing
the percent of jobs recovered since the
beginning of the pandemic by state
okay here are
the top states in terms of percentage of
jobs that have returned since the
beginning of the pandemic
utah idaho arizona texas montana south
dakota georgia nebraska tennessee south
carolina florida mississippi alabama
arkansas north carolina
not a blue state among them
he blew the only state that i just
listed that has a blue governor is north
carolina which again is a state that
tends to go red in presidential
elections
so every single state i just mentioned
in terms of jobs recovered percentage of
jobs recovered is a red state
every single one
but you have ronald klein saying that no
lockdown measures are actually helpful
to the economy
okay fine so if you believe that why not
just lock it all back down
now the answer is the markets think that
that's what these guys believe this is
why the the dow is just getting
destroyed okay so the dow finished 460
points lower
on tuesday
according to the cnbc the major averages
fell sharply giving up solid gains on
wednesday after the cdc and prevention
confirmed the first case of oh
micron in the u.s markets are not afraid
of omicron
markets are afraid of these insane
idiotic
public health officials locking down you
again that is what markets are afraid of
and they should be afraid of that
because these morons have run the
economy into the ground in what should
be the middle of the easiest recovery in
american history
because the economy was put into an
artificial coma last year
and then vaccines came and we were all
supposed to be like ready to go and now
they're talking about how stronger
coveted measures produce stronger
economic outcomes
it's no wonder that joe biden is down in
the high 30s low 40s in terms of public
approval rating meanwhile he's just out
there babbling nonsensically to himself
about economic matters he said yesterday
that he built the economic recovery no
you have stagnated in economic recovery
that was perfectly natural
and this guy is the the biggest
placebo effect when it comes to the
economy in american history except it
turns out that the placebo wasn't a
placebo he may be killing the patient
here is here's joe biden we're seeing
more new small businesses
higher wages and more disposable income
fewer children in poverty fewer people
getting unemployment checks
none of this was inevitable it was
because of the american rescue plan
which virtually every democrat in
congress voted for and every republican
voted against
it was because of the hard work my
administration has done to try to solve
the challenges in our economy instead of
just pointing fingers and complaining
nope you did not build the economic
recovery your economic recovery has been
rife with inflation which was completely
unnecessary because you decided to pay
people to stay home so even under supply
of labor we have supply chain shortages
and you blew money into the economy we
didn't need to do that we didn't need to
do it you did that what you built here
is the failure of the economy meanwhile
joe biden is still babbling to himself
about how his plan to battle inflation
is working really is it is it really
working so well here is joe biden saying
something completely nonsensical as is
his want prices are still out of sun
excuse me prices are still out of sync
as the world comes back
but as we continue to overcome these
obstacles
the more price pressures will ease
but i have not been content to sit back
and wait
i've used every tool available to
address the price increases and it's
working
really i is it working now because um
i'm because
actually jerome powell came out
yesterday and he said that inflation is
no longer transitory so is it is it
working particularly well joe is it
meanwhile joe biden is still promoting
more spending more spending buildback
better is going to fix everything now my
republican friends are talking a lot
about prices
but they're lined up against my
buildback better plan which would go
right at the problem for rising costs
for families
why's that
i don't want to speculate on anyone's
motive
but it's always easier to complain about
a problem than to try to fix it
oh really um i noticed that that's all
you do is complain about problems that
you yourself created
and uh and that you do nothing about
well your secretary of transportation is
on a two-month paternity leave
in the middle of supply chain crisis
meanwhile janet yellen saying the same
thing she's just lying also she said
janet yellen again these are all
political hacks whenever you see
the notion that there is a non-partisan
branch of the government
that is filled with political appointees
just remember secretary yellen was the
head of the federal reserve until five
minutes ago a non-partisan political
figure and here she is now just openly
lying about build back better not adding
to deficits it's not true according to
the cbo
these investments we expect will lead to
a gdp increase over the long term
without increasing the national debt or
deficit by a dollar
in fact the offsets in these bills mean
they actually reduce annual deficits
over time
okay so um yeah sure we believe you we
believe you the spiden administration by
the way
finally you end
at root the biden administration they're
just control freaks and angry old people
shouting at clouds so here's an angry
old man shouting at a cloud he's very
angry that people are noticing that
they're not being that they're not able
to uh
gain um
products during the christmas season
here's joe biden shouting at people for
noticing that their milk is more
expensive
if you watch the news recently you might
think the shelves in all our stores are
empty across the country
that parents won't be able to get
presents for their children on holidays
this holiday season
but here's the deal
for the vast majority of the country
that's not what's happening
because of the actions the
administration has taken in partnership
with business and labor retailers and
grocery stores freight movers and
railroads and those shelves are going to
be stocked
oh are they uh because that's not what
i'm hearing from all of the people who
are in industry right now
but it's you the people who are at fault
these your great rulers will be the ones
who eventually decide whether you are
allowed to have liberty or not
so i guess the leftist notion of
governance can be summed up in uh in the
following
logic you have the right to decide your
meaning of the universe of life of human
existence when it comes to killing
babies in your womb but when it comes to
your ability to actually live your life
freely we will tell you when you're
allowed to live your life freely at
least when you're not killing babies you
can kill babies that's the deal you can
kill as many babies as you want but can
you go to work today without a mask
well no that we will control
if this is the kind of governance you
look forward to keep voting blue
seriously and stay the hell out of my
state
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wire are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment